Transcriber: Ahmad Al Ashry
المدقّق: Muhammad Ramadan
منذ ثمانية أعوام إرتديت حظاظة صفراء
في يَدي.
كالتي هناك.
لم تتعود الناس التي تعرفني عَلَيّ
مرتديًا شئ في يدي
فكانوا يطلقون اسم حظاظة
علي ما أرتديه
فأصبحوا يروني مرتديا ما يطلقون عليه
حظاظة في أماكن عديدة كالأفراح والمناسبات
حتى وأنا مرتديًا البذلة
أرتدي الحظاظة.
فأستغرب الناس بعض الشئ
منذ خمسة أعوام، أُقيم سباق في الهرم
كان السباق للتوعية بسرطان الثدي
فقررت أن أشارك في السباق
وعندما ذهبت لتسجيل اسمي، التقيت بصديق
قال لي:أنا لا أنوي الجري
أنا ذاهب لأمرح
بعد السباق بعام، حلقت رأسي بأكمله
وهنا فقد الناس صوابهم وقالوا لي
ألا يكفيك ذلك الشئ الأصفر الذي ترتديه
بل وحلقت رأسك، هل أنت بخير؟
نعم أنا بخير، لكن الناس لم تكن
تعلم أن قبل كل هذا ب13 عامًا توفي جدي.
كنت في العاشرة من العمر في ذلك الوقت
ولم أفهم لماذا توفيّ.
كَبرتُ قليلاً، وعَلمتُ إنه توفي
إثر مرض السرطان.
لماذا لم يخبرني أحدًا وقتها؟ لا أحد يعلم!
رويدًا رويدًا، قفدت الكثير من الناس
بسبب مرض السرطان
وكلما سألت أحدًا عن سبب موتهم
يقول لا أعلم وهو يحدق بي
فأسئله هل تعلم ماهذا؟
يقول نعم إنه المرض الخبيث
وهو يحدق بي خوفًا
لماذا تموت الناس إذًا،
وهل يمكننا المساعدة؟
لا أحد يعلم!
أسئلة كتيرة جدًا ليس لها إجابة
الجميع خائفون، الجميع لا يعرفون الإجابة
فبدأت في البحث والقراءة علي الإنترنت
عن كيفية مساعدة مريض السرطان.
بدأت في القراءة، وتكوّن لدي فكرة
ووعي جزئي بالذي يشعر به المريض
سواء عن طريق ما قرأته علي الإنترنت
أو سواء عن طريق متابعتي لمرضى السرطان
وهنا بدأت أتسأل مرة أخري
هل يوجد بحث علمي للسرطان في مصر؟ا
وكانت الإجابة، لا قليل.
هل أنتم علي علم لماذا تموت هذه الناس؟
هل يساعدهم أحد أو يتحدث معهم؟ا
الإجابة، لا لا لا
وكانت هذه الإجابة متوقعة.
هل يمكن مساعدة هولاء الناس بأي شىء؟
أيضًا لا، جميعها إجابات متوقعة.
تشابه هذا السؤال
مع السؤال السابق والذي يليه
إجابات متوقعة لأن لا أحد يفهم ولأن
الجميع خائفون.
الخوف هو الذي يُميت الناس.
لا أحد يحيى وهو خائف.
نعم يكون لك وجود كشكل أو كصورة
ولكنك لا تكون حيًا.
هناك فرق كبير بين أن تكون حي،
وأن تكون موجود. لقد اختار الناس الخوف
واحتضنوه، وكرسوا جزء كبير من حياتهم له.
وبدلًا من أن يحاولوا فهم
طبيعة المرض، فروا هاربين.
منذ ذاك الوقت، تراءى لي أن على الناس
أن تتغير، وعليهم أن يفهموا.
وأن يكفوا عن الخوف ويحيوا.
فأصبحت كلما رأيت أحدهم
أذهب إليه وأقول لايوجد شيء
يسمي بالمرض الخبيث
وإنما اسمه السرطان.
وإن مثله مثل أي شيء
في هذه الحياة،
إذا قرر الإنسان
أن يصمد
ويستمر، سيشفى إن شاء الله.
في عام 2004 علمت عن مؤسسة
تُسمى Live Strong
وعَلِمتٌ كيف تساعد الناس
التي تعاني من المرض
علي الصعيد
النفسي في أمريكا
وكيف أصبح الناس
مؤمنين بإمكانية شفائهم،
وإنهم لن يتوقفواعن
العلاج ولن يُصيبهم
الإكتئاب ولن ينعزلوا.
في عام 2006 إرتديت
الحظاظة التابعة لLIVE STRONG
تكريمًا لجدي الذي توفى إثرالسرطان
لم أخلعها حتي اليوم.
في عام 2009 شاركت
في السباق الذي أقيم
في الهرم حتي أوضح ما معنى
أن تشارك في حدث ما
لتدعم قضية، لا من أجل
أن تحقق هدف نفسي.
كنا ۷۰۰۰ مشترك، ربحت السباق.
وبدأت في توضيح الفكرة.
(تصفيق)
في عام 2010 حلقت رأسي بأكمله للسرطان
لأول مرة، حتي يرى المٌصابون بالسرطان
أن هناك شخص ليس مريض، إختار
أن يصبح مثلهم
ويحلق رأسه للسرطان
وهذا شيء طبيعي
أن يتساقط شعرك من
العلاج ولاحظت نظرة الأمل في
عيونهم من بعد ما رأوا أن هناك إنسان
سليم اختار أن يصبح مثلهم
في آخر عام 2010 أخذت قرار بتكوين
فريق يساعد الناس المصابة بالسرطان.
وكانت أول إجابة قيلت لي من صديق
عندما حكيت له هي
"الله معك". كان يستهزئ
وكانت هذه بدابة الحكاية.
وكانت هذه بداية فكرة
تأسيس فريق Run for Yellow
لقد أردنا أسم يوحي للناس بالسرعة
في الهدف الذي نريد الوصول إليه.
ومن هنا جاء اسم Run for Yellow
والأصفر هنا يرمز للشفاء أو الصمود.
ولكن كيف سأساعد الناس؟
سأظل أجري وأحلق رأسي من أجل السرطان.
ويقيت متذكر ما قاله لي صديقي
عندما قلت له إني سوف
أذهب لأشارك في السباق، قال
"الوضع لا يحتمل تعب أكثر
من اللازم، نحن ذاهبين لنمرح"
يوجد العديد من الناس مثل صديقي.
فكيف سأذهب لكل شخص
وأُشجعه على أن يقود دراجة
لعشرة كيلومترات
أو أن يجري خمسة كيلومترات
أو حتى أن يمشي لثلاثة
كيلومترات، فهم بالكاد يذهبون إلى الجامعة.
وكلما أذهب لأتحدث مع أحدهم. يظن
أني أريد أن أجمع المال أو بعض التبرعات
ولكن ليس هذا ما نريد.
نحن نريد من الناس أن تقود دراجتها
وأن تسير لبعض الكيلومترات
وأن يبذلوا بعض من المجهود.
وذاك لأن عندما يري مريض السرطان أن
هناك شخصًا سليم يفعل كل هذا
سيشعر أن هناك شخصًا يسانده ويدعمه
مما سيمنحه أمل ألا يستسلم للألم.
هنا تراءى لنا إننا يجب أن نوضح كل هذا
إلى الجميع. ولكن كيف سنفعل ذلك؟
خطر ببالنا أن نقيم حفلة
مثل أي شخص، حتى
نَأتي بأكبر قدر من الناس في مكان واحد
ونوضح فكرتنا. اُقيمت الحفلة
ولكنها خالفت توقعاتنا
وابتعدت عن إطار السرطان.
وكانت هذه أول وآخر مرة نقيم فيها حفلة
ولكننا نجحنا في أن نوضح فكرتنا للناس.
بعدها بقليل قررنا أن نقيم أحداث
رياضية فقط، حيث نقود الدراجات
مثلًا في حدث، ونجري في حدث آخر،
أو نزور المدارس المختلفة ونحمس الطلاب
ونوضح لهم ما هو السرطان ونُزيل خوفهم منه
ونُخبرهم إنه يسمى السرطان
وليس المرض الخبيث.
من الممكن أيضًا أن نجري
ونَقود الدراجات في نفس الحدث.
لقد قمنا بالكثير من الأحداث حتى
لاحظ المشاركون في الأحداث نتيجة ما فعلوه،
وخاصةً إن جميع الأحداث
التي كنا قد أقامنَها كانت مجانية،
وستظل مجانية.
وبعد أن قُدنا الدراجات وجَرينا وفعلنا
كل شيء كان لابد من أن نبتكر
أشياءً جديدة في أحداثنا؛
فصنعنا منتجات ووضعنا على هذه
المنتجات اسم فريقنا،
وقمنا ببيعها للناس بصورة اختيارية
عادةً يأتي الناس إلى الحدث
ويقوموا بالجري أو يقودوا الدراجات
مجانًا، وإذا أرادوا التبرع
يقومون بشراء منتج
من منتجاتنا
في نفس الوقت تمكنت
من التواصل مع ناس كثيرين
ومن ناحية أخرى، أنقل
مال التبرعات الي مستشفيات
السرطان.
قررنا بعد ذلك أن نُغير من شكل أحداثنا،
فأعطينا الأعضاء ملصقات
ليحملونها على طول الطريق
أثناء الجري أو قيادة الدراجات.
هذه الملصقات تحمل جُمل
حماسية تذُكر الناس بسبب وجودهم
هنا اليوم ونزبد من تركيزهم
في الهدف وراء ما يفعلونه.
ثم قمنا بعدها بحملة وأسمينها
Circle Of Hope
في Circle of Hope أحضرنا الجميع وجعلناهم
يفعلون أشياء كانوا
خائفون من فعلها
الجميع خائفون من أن
يتحدثوا، الجميع سواء
كانوا مصابين بسرطان
أم لا، الجميع
خائفون من أن يتحدثون
ويبوحون بما في أعماقهم.
أحضرنا الجميع سواءً كانوا
مرضى سرطان أم لا
وجعلناهم يتحدثون
وجعلناهم يشعروا إنه
أمر طبيعي أن يكونوا مرضى سرطان
إنه أمر طبيعي أن يتساقط شعرهم
وإنهم مثلهم مثل الجميع. نتيجة لذلك
فعل الناس ما كانوا يهابونه
فأصبحوا يقولون "نحن مصابون
بالسرطان وليس بالمرض الخبيث"
أصبحوا يحاربون المرض بعد أن
كانوا مستسلمين وأصبحوا يحضرون أحداثنا
هل تعلمون ما كان سيحدث إذا كنا نظمنا
أحداث هدفها جمع التبرعات فقط؟
كنا لجمعنا الكتير من المال أو التبرعات
وكنا لأنفقناها، ولكن ماذا كنا
لنفعل عندما تنتهي هذه التبرعات؟!
أثبت الكثير من الأطباء
سواء أكانوا في مصر أم خارجها
أن العلاج النفسي أهم بكثير من العلاج الطبي
أو العلاج الكيميائي حيث إنه يُساعد
المريض على الخروج مما يمر به ويمنحه أمل
ذات مرة اتصل بي صديق وقال
" ألو كيف حالك؟
لقد اكتشفت أني مصاب بسرطان"
فسألته "مصاب بالسرطان؟ سرطان إيه؟
فأجَاب "سرطان الرئة". ما لا يعلمه الجميع
عن سرطان الرئة، أنه من أنواع السرطانات
أو من الأمراض القليلة التي يجهل الجمبع
نقطة تحولها التي توْدي إلى الموت
ففجأة يأتي المرض،
وفجأة يستسلم المريض
فتحدث نقطة التحول
ويموت المريض باستثناء
من كان يحارب المرض.
لذلك كنت أعلم أن فرصة صديقي ضئيلة جدًا
في النجاة خاصةً إنه كان في المرحلة
الثالثة وهذا المرض يتكون
من أرْبع مراحل، ولكنني لم استسلم
وقررت أن نواصل معركتنا.
إتصلت بكل من يعرفه
وحلقت رأسي وحلق الجميع رؤسهم وصنعنا
جميعًا فيديو وصورنا أنفسنا
ونحن نتحدث معه ونتمنى له الشفاء.
سافر صديقنا بعد مُدة ليُجري بعض التحاليل
ويُكمل علاجه في الخارج
بعد فترة اتصل بنا صديقنا
من هناك وقال لي
لقد أَجريت التحاليل وظهرت النتيجة
فسألته وما هي نتيجتها؟
فقال لي "لقد شُفيت"
"بدونكم كنت سأموت."
(تصفيق)
قادة LIVESTRONG في فرنسا يفعلون
شيء عظيمًا جدًا وهذا الشيء
موجودة أيضًا في أكثر من بلد
ولكن هذه الفكرة تنتمي لفرنسا
في الأساس. يذهب القادة لشركات
ال Ipads
ويطلبوا منهم الIpads كنوع من
أنواع التبرع ثم يعطوها
إلى مستشفيات ومعاهد السرطان.
ولكن قبل أن يعطوهم الIpads يأخذونها
ويضعوا عليها جُمل ومقاطع وصور حماسية
ثم يَعطوهم للمصابين بالسرطان
الجالسين في جلسة العلاج الكيميائي لتُحمسهم
فبدلًا من أن يكون المريض.
جالسًا هناك وهو متألم
وبدلًا من أن يكون جالسًا
هناك وهو يعلم إنه سيموت
تتحول هذه االIpads بما
تحمله لشيء يذكره إنه لن يموت
لشيء يذكره إنه سينهض
وهذا هو الدعم النفسي الذي
أتحدث عنه، أن يكون هناك شيء
دائمًا يُذكرك بكل هذا سواء
أكان ال Ipad أم شخص يُحادثك.
مستشفيات سرطان الأطفال بأمريكا
يفعلون شيء مذهل، حيث يأتون بعبوة
العلاج الكيميائي التي سيعطونها للطفل
ويغطونها بصورة
لبطل خارق كسوبر مان
أو بات مان أو فلاش.. إلخ
ثم يخبرون الطفل أن وقت الجرعة الخارقة
أو القوة الخارقة الخاصة بك قد حان
فيتيقن الطفل أنه من الممكن أن يتألم الآن،
ولكن هذه الجرعة ستحوله لاحقًا
إلى سوبرمان؛ فلا يستسلم للألم.
كيف يستسلم وهو يعلم أنه
سيتحول لسوبرمان في يوم من الأيام؟
في سبتمبرعام 2013 كنت في رحلة عمل
وأثناء سفري من تونس إلى الأردن،
سألتني زميلتي في العمل التي كانت جالسة
بجواري في الطائرة عن سبب
ارتدائي للحظاظة،
وعن سبب ارتدائي إياها حتى
في المؤتمر وأنا مُرتدي
البذلة لا أحد يفعل هذا
وسألتني لماذا نصف صوري على
فيسبوك وتويتر وأنا حالق رأسي
فـشرحت لها ماذا أفعل بجانب عملي
أي Run for Yellow وشرحت لها أهميته
فقالت لي "الله معك "ولكن هذه المرة
ليس باستهزاء.
وبعد أرْبع أيام، فوجئت بها ترسل
لي صورة لها، وتقول إنها حلقت رأسها
للسرطان فقلت لها "ماذا حلقتي رأسك !!!"
قالت لي "نعم لقد حلقت رأسي للسرطان"
هذه السيدة التي حلقت رأسها
أم لطفلين، تبلغ 34 عامًا
ومتزوجة أي أنها آخر شخص في هذا
العالم من الممكن أن يحلق رأسه.
وعندئذ فقط أيقنت أنه ليس
من اللازم أن أرتدي الحظاظة أو أحلق رأسي
لأوضح لشخص أمرًا، فمن الممكن أن أتحدث معه
وأثبت له، وأُحَمسه، فيُحدث هو أيضًا
اختلاف، وهذه هي أقل وأبسط مساعدة
من الممكن أن يُقدمها لنا الناس
ليس الغرض من الأمر أن تحلق رأسك
فقط بل أن توْمن بقُدراتك. وهذا يأتي
من أعماقك عندما تكون على يقين
أنك أقوى من أقوى سرطان،
وأقوى من أقوى عاصفة تواجها في الطريق
جميعنا نواجه تحديات كثيرة، واليوم سنواجه
تحدي جديد.
كيف نواجه هذا التحدي وكيف
نراه أو ننظر له، هو ما يحدد
هل سنتخطاه أم سنعلق به،
هل سيكسرنا ويُغيرنا، أم سيُحدث فقط خدش.
علامة بسيطة ونظل متذكرين طوال حياتنا أن
وراءها قصة كفاح كبيرة تجعلنا نفتخر
بذلك الشخص الذي نحن عليه الآن.
هيا تتفق على أن العلامات هي أثر الجروح
والخدوش التي حدثت أثر التحديات وإنها
أفضل شيْ حدث لنا في حياتنا. هيا نتخيل
إننا عند الولادة كنا لوحة خالية
لونها أبيض وإذا نظرنا إليها الأن سنجد ألف
دليل ودليل
على إننا عشنا وصعدنا من جديد وأن الشمس
قد أشرقت علينا بعد ظلام طويل بعد أن قلنا
إنها لن تشرق وإن هناك مئة دليل آخر
على إننا صعدنا وأكَملنا وسقطنا
وأشياء كثيرة
أخرى، بعد ما كانت اللوحة خالية.
إن الوقت قد حان، هيا بنا نصنع
علامات جديدة، علامات تهز العالم
بأكمله.
أنا اسمي لؤي علي، وأكبر علامة في هي
إنني أحلق رأسي للسرطان.
(تصفيق)